nassim civil et ancien ambassadeur
d'israël en france
nassim vili merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors tout d'abord
selon toute vraisemblance que devrait
annoncer concrètement benyamin
nétanyahou je vais y a il ya un bon
prudents et à une image différente entre
les l'intention de netanyahou et ce qui
se passe sur le terrain
le sujet de l'annexion des territoires
le sujet auquel aujourd'hui des lustres
et liens sont complètement indifférent
je ne m'intéresse pas ils ont très
inquiet de la crise économique
ils sont très inquiètes il retourne de
la grosne à la situation politique dans
la région
les inquiète aussi aujourd'hui vraiment
ils vont très bien
c'est pour ça que le croc le prix est
compris aussi que étant donné que d'un
côté la société israélienne sms de
l'autre côté
l'administration américaine n'a pas pris
de décision ferme
il a peur d'un échec ça veut dire que
malgré qu'il a promises c'est une
promesse qui peut pas tenir
ça va être retardé de quelques jours et
ça va être une mini addiction rien que
cette brique mais le croco au point de
vue politique ça change pas la situation
alors ma vie politique nissim zvili que
signifierait l'annexion pour la
population palestinienne en général et
pour l'autorité autonome de
mahmoud abbas en particulier des fois
que je suis le sud près de réaction des
palestiniens surtout de l'autorité
palestinienne le papa de sa masse et des
dieux du gouvernement justinien dans la
cisjordanie et je comprenne pas
exactement ce qu'il veut parce que d'un
côté il coopère complètement avec israël
au niveau sécuritaire parce que c'est
dans leur intérêt d'arrêter le ramasse
tout débloquer le ramadan l'arrêté de se
développer et de l'autre côté aussi un
atout économique parce qu'il ya des
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
travaillent en selle et c'est un des
leviers économiques les plus importantes
pour le pdc et de l'udc deuxième copé
une réussite bas à assen est valable
pour recevoir un soutien suffisant de la
communauté ou des pays arabes
et c'est une vraiment ceux d'un soutien
complètement symbolique par quelques des
leaders qui font des discours contre le
trône et mais devant qui ne proposent
pas il est il ne présente pas vraiment
leur vision de l'avenir
on est en train de patauger dans la même
situation qui plus de dix ans quel deal
encore il y avait un espoir je parle
plus l'accord d'oslo par la veille avait
encore un espoir qu'on est en train de
négocier comp la vue d'un accord un char
tétouan où selon des factures d eau
il y aura qu il y a des quelles
solutions
les linceuls solution si elle toujours
des éléments
ce qu'on comprend bien ce qui devenu un
peu plus complet
qui est pardonné ou la liaison
téléphonique n'est pas très bonne en
tout cas merci nissim zvili pour cet
éclairage elle je rappelle que vous êtes
ancien ambassadeur d'israël en france